2 19.30 69 etwas war das 11 11 13 27 von
ihnen anderen seite das ist ja total
schlimm hindert mich bei dir noch einen
block zwischen uns sonst hast du fünf
fackeln
danke gott dass er total kacke altair
siebels dunkel
warum wohl
alter mann ist riesig man überhaupt dem
level
du hast meine texte oder wie
wahrscheinlich so wird sich das wird
ungefähr schon die hälfte abgebaut haben
aber ihn nicht haben dass wir so ein
pech haben wir sind einfach behindert
doch
keine hobbys elsbeth rock ist und dort
gucken welche flexibel nicht die da oben
hahaha ich habe man irgendwann ja ich
glaube es auch
das kann nicht sein oder doch
wer bist du
tf
ja dagegen seine pickel raus
ich werde hier oben irgendwo welcher
noch kein fackel mehr
also ich habe noch ein paar
alter sie wieder geht
also ich würd ja nicht die stein
spitzhacke aufbrauchen
ja ich bekomme hier wieder weiter raus
hier geht's auch nähe gezielt in das ist
schon alles eine grenze ich dachte das
wäre endlich mensch das macht mir
richtig spaß hier war die geht's nach
oben 26 theoretisch insel es geht
überall nach oben 2 es regnet
hier geht's auch noch lang
wo er
lasst uns einander gehen und gucken die
seitengänge die wollte ich gerade machen
hier geht's auch noch da ist desto
besser
geil ja ich freue mich ja ich bin so ein
tier auch ich habe ein buch gefunden
ich hab's tags anderem namen das pokern
like des quest der spk version of the
old treasure hunter 1.04 forums
käfer braucht nicht die steine habe ich
doch gar nicht heraf ich habe noch drei
herzen
hast du mir gesagt ich hab so viele
items 9
da ist
das sind quiz
das kann nicht
in italien können dahinter liegen das
zombie oder hässlich dass holland ich
hab jetzt ist österreich austria
das ist bitter check point
martin der knoten
der ganze sap
im spiel noch aus sagt einfach how much
we knew this room 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
das bestimmt falsch als richtig okay gut
ach du scheiße als 2 3 532 handys müssen
im kopf machen als unsere kosten 4490 96
11 hatte die zahl schreibe ich kurz im
chat man muss die letzten beiden also 66
74 4466 76 so dass beim wiederum plus
sagen wir erstmal bis 273 1 das sind fvf
1609 19.11 1619 elfter platz drei ist
sich ich war ganz verwirrt weil das
steht da nicht weiter
1619 das sind dann auch nur damit die
teil nicht mehr sieht ich kann auch so
macht er auf hier stimmt das
22 29 10 30 69 witzig als was war das 11
13 27
luca will kann das hier den ganzen tag
so hätte ich im garten ich hab geraten
es ist wieder da - ich mag - nicht mehr
kommt null raus ich rate wieder alles
offen
es seien klicks genauso schaffe ich auch
die ganzen guten noten in mathe arbeiten
hast du den schalter schon gedrückt
hat man ja letztens debatte gesehen was
war deine matte das heißt sehr
verzweifelt aus ich aber gar nicht ich
habe überlegt weil ich empfehle ich mit
der klausur dann wirst du nie was nur
machen sollte ja er war ja gerade ob wir
dann noch mal hin
ihr bisher ein mann ist nach reiter ich
freue mich ich hab noch bücher und alles
hier warte ich sage mal in sachen da ja
stimmt das ist eine gute idee
ach ich hab dich dein später auch 1
geben ok alter dafür ist jetzt alle
holzschwerter er hier unternehmen so
hohe alter hilfe doch ich bin schon
weiter doch ich bin tot nein ich bin bei
austrias pont natürlich hast du das ja
du musst die nicht wird nennen was
einmal durchlaufen ok du schaffst das
super aber ich hab dir fasst das also
ich hab alle getötet bis auf 2
hier verlangt noch egal ist aber über
fackeln und somit was ich nehme einfach
mal die betten mit
da hatte dann geht plötzlich rein weil
sonst fällst aus der welt martin geht da
nicht rein zu spät
ja aber dann fällt gleich aus dem
eingang wir können unsere betten 80 sind
doch sogar betten diese nicht einfach
also ich hab alle tot gemacht ja dann
kommt kurz zurück und setzten
exportieren kann ich nicht du musst es
auf die trader blade gehen
dankeschön
klickt man im kopf du liegt mit dem kopf
an den füßen nach keine waffen
das ist was übrig geblieben ist
stein schwert es gibt nur noch 1 das
könnte natürlich dir ne also meine ganze
sind der oh gott oh gott bastelbogen
nein vielleicht sollte man camions
daraus was und die danisco plätten
okay okay okay
wahrscheinlich hat man gerade ich bin
tot die opfer oder ist ein zombie
village oh schön deine hose liegt hier
hier ist ein schwert ich hab meins ich
gebe mich gebaut und ab sommer von dir
ja ich habe auch ein paar sachen noch
was ich blättere okay gut ich bin
eigentlich ganz gesichert und weiter
gehen warte ich für auch noch geheilt
da geht's aber die bild ab ich brauche
ihm den bogen oder sonova ok weiter
geht's
wir können erst mal die spinnen töten
weil die kommen nicht durch die tür
durch auch zombie pacman wartet die
nehmen wir das alte lied eine rüstung
aber der kommt nicht durch weil ich den
weg puncher ob du schlägst mich erst mal
sorry geronimo alter ist nicht mehr viel
los
ganz ruhig rein kommen ich hatte die
ganze zeit diese mine karte
ich muss auch mal wieder neben aufnahmen
scheiße
die anderen monstern luft zu sprengen
ich bin im moment tut muss das essen
dort wo ich bin noch am leben
ja ich nicht
er halte das eine menge erfahrung
das gepäck wird allerdings der luft
gesprengt die wand ja okay das war's das
war scheiße doch nicht moment mal kurz
ich muss mich kurz organisieren erstmal
trieb adele alles in luft sprengt schön
oh gott nur krieg hier hast doch gut
dann springe ich nicht alle
gegenwärtigen luft ich warte aber ich
komme
komme zur befreiung des bösen guten
kiesel durch
ja ich hab's geschafft scheiße george
hallo mit geschafft da waren noch
irgendwo da bin ich rein gefallen
november wenn ihm schon 50 minuten aus
so muss das sein
theoretisch können jetzt auch noch
fertig machen mit weil es dort müsse man
hoffe ich doch
ob's noch maximal so bekomme ich diese
scheiß leiter nicht hoch muss der druck
halten
dabei und dabei nach vorne
das sieht interessant aus dem 12
ist echt zu dürfen ja space gedrückt
halten und dabei nach vorne gedrückt
halten
was du machst es jetzt gemacht
ich merke
es passiert nichts passierte
man muss einen bestimmten in einer
bestimmten reihenfolge drücken scheiß
drauf
corning cent erwartet fällt sand runter
in botschaft ok moment ich würde mal
sagen wir machen erstmal so alle
hintereinander moment da kann man runter
springen
dann gucken was passiert das wenn ich
hier drauf gehen wo bist du
ich glaube nicht dass es richtig ist was
ich gemacht habe
warum weiß ich nicht scheint so als
jetzt einfach so weitergehen
die sind raptors aber da man aber hier
geht es hoch oder ja das ist wohl kann
man hat man wolle kaputt machen
nein aber hier geht es jetzt doch jetzt
sind uns so weiter hier sind porsche
noch zwölften das wartet die branche um
darüber zu springen zu können dass wolf
denkt sich das muss man trinken
ich habe ihm die kiste
man schwinge gehen hier sind nur lohn
und leitern beamten dingens okay gut
weiß nicht ob das meine art weg
geschubst
wo wir unsere sachen hätten rein dingen
sollen glaube ich zurückspringen und
jetzt muss er wieder hoch laufen dann
vergesse die ketten zu gehen als eine
halbe gemacht habe ich gemacht
es hat nichts passiert hier
hier ist zu
hallo hoch da so geht das nicht mit den
leitern ach du warst das ging wirklich
nicht ja wenn wir gegen das lokal ich
glaub du kommst hier nicht mehr rein
woran warum ich war so eine blogger vor
sind ich bin froh wenn ich erst mal hoch
komme ich verstehe auch gar nicht was
ich machen muss ich bin jetzt hier oben
aber game 13 ist offen das heißt du
kannst dich theoretisch zu importieren
teleportieren
auf friedlich umstellen find ich hoffe
erstmal schlafen
lukas oft ist es auch besser friedlich
machen
120 tausend müssen wir machen sonst geht
das nicht so
messer friedlich stellen
feinde schoppel der völlig kaputt machen
und friedlich umstellen
horn ein scheiße
nur gesagt damit wenig von gas
attackiert werden oder so